Off 1.
Autour des années 1600, Galilée monta en
haut de la Tour de Pise pour l’une des premières
démonstrations d’expérience scientifique
de l’Histoire.
De là-haut, Galilée laissa tomber deux boules
de poids différents.
Alors que le public s’attendait à voir
la boule la plus lourde tomber plus vite,
à la surprise générale, les deux boules
atteignirent le sol en même temps.
Bon j’ai fait l’expérience.
Et ce n’est pas ce que j’ai vu...
[...]
À l’école, on nous dit que si on fait
l’expérience, on est sensé conclure que
les boules tombent toutes à la même vitesse.
C’est la loi de la chute des corps de Galilée,
nous dit-on.
Sauf que…
Sauf que c’est faux.
Si on fait l’expérience, on voit la boule
la plus lourde tomber plus vite.
Du coup, on ne peut pas conclure que les deux
boules tombent à la même vitesse.
À l’école toujours, on nous dit aussi
que si, en pratique, la boule la plus lourde
tombe plus vite, c’est parce qu’elle est
moins freiné par les frottements de l’air.
Et c’est tout à fait juste.
Si on refait l’expérience, mais qu’on
enlève complètement l’air avant de laisser
tomber les boules, on observe que les boules
tombent à la même vitesse.
C’est une expérience que Brian Cox a faite
sur la BBC.
Mais il faut voir les moyens requis pour faire
une telle expérience.
Brian Cox fait ça dans une tour gigantesque
et avec un vide excellent.
Il n’y a aucune chance que Galilée ait
fait ça.
Il avait juste pas les moyens techniques de
faire un tel vide.
Ce n’est donc pas en jetant des boules de
très haut qu’il a découvert sa loi de
la chute des corps.
Off 2.
En fait, l’histoire de la Tour de Pise est
complètement inventée de toute pièce.
Sans doute par l’étudiant de Galilée pour
vulgariser sa loi de la chute des corps.
Et quand on y réfléchit, c’est forcément
une histoire inventée.
En effet, s’il avait fait l’expérience,
Galilée aurait vu l’objet le plus lourd
tomber plus vite, confirmant ainsi la théorie
dominante de la chute des corps.
À l’époque, on considérait qu’Aristote
était le plus grand savant de tous les temps.
Et Aristote avait affirmé que les objets
les plus lourds tombaient plus vite.
ET C’ÉTAIT TOUT SAUF DÉBILE.
En effet, l’expérience confirmait la loi
de la chute des corps d’Aristote.
Mais du coup, si Galilée n’a pas fait l’expérience
de la tour de Pise, comment a-t-il pu oser
réfuter la pensée d’Aristote ? Comment
a-t-il pu imaginer que les corps tombaient
bien tous à la même vitesse s’il n’avait
pas fait d’expérience pour le prouver directement
? Et, surtout, qu’est-ce qui l’a amené
à croire en sa loi ? Pourquoi a-t-il fini
par penser ce qu’il a pensé ?
Ce que je trouve très triste, c’est que
ce n’est que récemment, bien des années
après mes derniers cours de physique, que
j’ai enfin découvert des réponses satisfaisantes
à ces questions passionnantes…
Et en gros, on peut avancer quatre explications.
Off 3.
Pour commencer, Galilée a bel et bien fait
des expériences de chute des corps.
Ce qui fut remarquable, c’est que plus le
vide était vide, et moins la différence
entre la chute d’une balle et d’une plume
était grande.
Il semblait que si le vide était parfait,
la différence pourrait être nulle.
Mais ça, ça prouve rien.
D’abord, il était difficile de vérifier
que les deux corps arrivaient au sol vraiment
en même temps.
Et surtout, on pouvait rétorquer que la hauteur
de chute n’était pas assez grande pour
observer une différence.
Off 4.
Galilée étudia ensuite la chute de boules
le long de plans inclinés.
La chute des boules étant plus lente, Galilée
réussit à mieux comparer les chutes de deux
boules différentes.
Elles étaient quasi-identiques.
Par ailleurs, Galilée nota qu’il fallait
quatre fois plus de temps pour parcourir deux
fois plus de distance.
Autrement dit, la vitesse d’une boule augmente
au fur et à mesure qu’elle tombe.
La boule accélère.
Oui, mais là encore, on peut se dire que
les boules roulent et tombent pas vraiment.
Du coup, c’est pas tout à fait la même
chose.
Et puis, les différences de poids entre les
boules n’étaient peut-être pas suffisamment
grandes pour observer des différences significatives
dans leurs accélérations…
Off 5.
Galilée étudia aussi les trajectoires des
boulets de canon, dont les enjeux militaires
étaient cruciaux.
Galilée découvrit ainsi que ces trajectoires
étaient paraboliques.
Mieux encore, il remarqua que ces trajectoires
correspondaient à une accélération constante
vers le bas, et que ces trajectoires étaient
les mêmes pour tous les boulets de canon,
et même pour d’autres objets comme les
fontaines.
Voilà qui suggérait que tout tombait avec
une même accélération d’environ 10 mètres
par seconde par seconde.
Ça commence à devenir convaincant…
Mais pas décisif.
L’argument conclusif de Galilée est un
tout autre argument, qui est de loin mon préféré.
Cet argument est implacable.
Il s’agit d’un argument purement théorique,
qui consiste à prouver que la loi d’Aristote
n’a aucune chance d’être vraie.
Elle est forcément fausse.
Dans notre univers.
Comme dans tout autre univers…
Off 6.
L’idée géniale de Galilée fut de considérer
la chute de deux corps différents attachés
l’un à l’autre.
Disons que l’on a par exemple attaché une
pastèque et une pomme avec un fil.
Question.
La pastèque attachée à une pomme tombera-t-elle
plus vite ou moins vite que la pastèque seule
? Et là où Galilée est vraiment malin,
c’est que plutôt que de chercher à utiliser
sa loi de la chute des corps pour répondre
à cette question, il va chercher à déterminer
les prédictions que font la loi d’Aristote,
celle qui dit que les objets plus lourds tombent
plus vite.
Off 6.
D’un côté, la pastèque plus la pomme
forment un système plus lourd que la pastèque
seule.
D’après la loi d’Aristote, c’est donc
la pastèque attachée à la pomme qui doit
tomber plus vite que la pastèque seule.
Off 6.
Mais d’un autre côté, la pastèque attachée
à la pomme est attachée à un objet plus
léger qu’elle.
D’après la loi d’Aristote, la pastèque
va tomber plus vite que la pomme, si bien
que la pomme va être amenée à freiner la
chute de la pastèque telle un parachute.
La pastèque est donc freinée dans sa chute.
Elle tombe donc moins vite que si elle tombait
seule !
La loi d’Aristote prédit donc une chose
et son contraire.
Elle est donc inconsistente ! Incroyable ! Avec
une expérience de pensée lumineuse qui m’a
pris 1 minute a expliqué, Galilée a démontré
une fois pour toute que la loi d’Aristote
était fausse, et serait toujours fausse.
Et par conséquent, les objets les plus lourds
ne tombent pas plus vite.
Tous les corps tombent avec la même accélération.
Et Galilée l’a prouvé indépendamment
de toute expérience.
Pire que ça, il a prouvé sa loi malgré
l’expérience.
Et ça, ça devrait vous faire réfléchir
à ce que l’on appelle l’épistémologie,
c’est-à-dire la manière dont “sait”
des choses.
Parmi les pires criminels de la cour de justice
de la science, on trouve les théories complotistes
du web, les expériences personnelles, ce
que j’ai révassé la nuit dernière et,
tout en bas, on a les théories inconsistentes,
celles à qui on réserve la peine capitale.
Ces théories ont été abattues par les sciences
à jamais, car elles sont pire que archi-fausses.
Not even wrong, comme le disait le physicien
Wolfgang Pauli pour ridiculiser bon nombres
de théories pseudo-scientifiques…
Une théorie inconsistente ne sera jamais
vrai, peu importe la montagne de “preuves”
que vous aurez pour la défendre.
Et ce que je trouve vraiment dommage, c’est
qu’on n’insiste que trop rarement sur
l’importance de la consistence des théories,
notamment dans la “méthode scientifique”,
dont on dit souvent que Galilée serait le
père.
Pourtant, si Galilée a découvert ses lois,
c’est rarement en ayant suivi cette “méthode
scientifique”.
Le plus souvent, à travers notamment ses
fameuses expériences de pensée, il a simplement
cherché à garantir autant que possible la
consistence, la clarté et la simplicité
de ses théories, que ce soit pour la loi
de la chute des corps, le principe de relativité
ou l’héliocentrisme.
Les observations n’étaient ensuite que
davantage d’arguments pour consolider ces
théories, ou les réfuter.
Et quand je dis ça, j’ai aussi en tête
la théorie de l’évolution de Darwin.
La raison principale pour laquelle j’y crois
n’a rien à voir avec les observations.
Il s’agit avant tout d’une théorie merveilleusement
consistente, surtout depuis la découverte
de l’ADN, mais aussi et surtout, ultra-limpide
et incroyablement simple.
Bon, bien sûr, les découvertes de fossiles,
la phylogénie ou la génétique contribuent
à rendre cette théorie encore plus crédible.
Mais je pense que si on raisonnait uniquement
en termes de consistence, de clarté et de
simplicité des théories, on conclurait immédiatement
que tout un tas de théories pseudo-scientifiques
sont sans intérêt…
Comme, par exemple, cette loi
de
la
chute
des
corps d’Aristote…